you all know PETA their very name is Pro
animal right well then why in the world
would PETA object to a proposal to make
the sweet cuddly beautiful wonderful
Labrador Retriever the state dog of Ohio
what's the problem with that so we
thought would ask PETA Associate
Director Ashley Byrne who joins us from
LA and we're delighted she's with us
Ashley okay so again four people were
watching they don't kind of follow the
controversies about shelter dogs where
it says dogs that are bred Ohio wants to
have the dog as its official dog and
other states have dogs as their official
dogs which was a new to me until today
we have dogs that are like the Catahoula
dog which is Louisiana's dog we have
Alaska the Malamute we have New
Hampshire the Chinook I thought that was
a helicopter we had Pennsylvania the
Great Dane and a but so why are you guys
at PETA upset that the lab is going to
be Ohio's official dog well don't get me
wrong we love all dogs and we love it
when people make a point of recognizing
how wonderful dogs are the problem is
that when you do something to promote a
specific dog breed what we see is you
know people running out and buying lots
of those dogs and that means lots of
those dogs eventually ending up in
shelters after they've been purchased or
after they've been purchased on a whim
sorry and also lots of dogs being bred
by puppy mills where they're kept in to
pleura boleyn ditions it also means less
dogs less mutts being adopted from
shelters fewer nose so you're worried so
you're worried that because Ohio will
name the lab as its official dog that
all these random Ohioans who apparently
have never heard of the lab before will
suddenly be it I mean I get your point
and I want to say I want to point this
out to you Ashley okay I had two labs
beloved dogs Troy who was 13 and also
Lucy who lived to age six they'll let
there's Lucy god rest her soul I do I do
believe dogs go to heaven I know that
sacrifice oh that's Lucy
but now actually actually I now have two
rescue dogs one I'm gonna feet we're
gonna show now Jimmy the junkyard dog
hold on we got to put Jimmy up so Ashley
there's Jimmy he looks very guilty
not even Kenny he looks very guilty but
I agree with you I love rescue dogs and
I support rescue dogs I support shelters
I do a lot but I think this is where
PETA kind of loses people does it he
said I don't think I'm gonna run out
they already know the lab is the most
popular dog in the United States the big
hunting dog bomb sniffing dog so I don't
think it's gonna like make people go out
and get the labs see I'm saying so I
think people like Peters lost its mind
they're gonna throw like ink on fur and
stuff again I mean I think people think
you kind of lose people with that you
know I know what you mean and we know
that this bill is well-intentioned but
we've seen this before when the movie
101 Dalmatians came out people rushed
out and bought Dalmatians and so many of
those dogs ended up in shelters it was a
crisis also though you know if someone
is set on a specific breed of dog
including a lab they should know that of
the six to eight million dogs who end up
in shelters every year about 25% of
those dogs are pure breads and in fact
if you go on the website pet finder
right now you can see that over 19,000
Labrador retrievers in the US right now
are homeless or looking for good
actually I can't even go to a shelter
like my kids and I we have nothing to do
we just go to shelters that's like our
thing on the weekend and I'm and
Raymond's gonna laugh because I'll
variably bring home another animal
because I can't stand it I can't stand
with dogs don't have home so I I do get
it but I think there's got to be like a
happy some kind of happy medium between
the purebred people and the shelter
people and I think we got to work it out
but if you can adopt a dog I like
adopting children and I like adopting
dogs I think it's I think it's all a
good night
wonderful and as for those Dalmatians
did did they would have happened to them
they end up getting euthanized all those
cute Dalmatians because you know I do
like Dalmatians but karela two villages
should get them all what about about
half of the animals who end up in
shelters every year half of
six to eight million ending up in
shelters do end up euthanized for lack
of good homes and I've got to tell you
you know for four dogs you know the
people who run puppy mills and pet
stores are Cruella De Vil because they
are sentencing shelter dogs to death
every time and I think there's some good
protections that Ohio has put in place
john Kasich's done it and that's good
stuff
Ashleigh it's great to have you on thank
you so much